he's Brian Regan back in the man cave
been doing stand-up comedy for how many
years how many decades uh I don't know
you thirty three or four decades yeah
good for you any decades when did you
decide to become a comedian I was in
college I uh I took a speech class and I
used to try to make my speeches funny
and one time I did okay I got the class
laughing you know 25 kids in the class
and I got the teacher laughing ooh this
woman sitting in the back howling and
I'm like a half never impressed a
teacher with anything in my life and I
remember walking back to the dorm after
that speech class and something had
happened in my head like I remember this
rug though
well I remember thinking I don't feel
like this when I walk back from biology
class you know I mean like like
something got in me whereas like
whatever that was I need I need more of
that but what do you okay what's your
next move who do you tell where you go I
think I want to be a comedian
it's weird dang man you know I didn't
really tell anybody I mean I told a
couple of clothes for you don't go home
and tell mom and dad no no no that they
probably wouldn't be thrilled but right
go to college no that's that's a big
call to mom and dad um no I just kind of
kept it to myself I told some close
friends and you know but when you hear
that laugh and there's nothing there's
no other sound like that it feels like
that to a comedian hearing that yeah
Fritzie and I we were talking about at
the Super Bowl
have you played caroline's of course
okay yeah
Caroline's many times in New York City
legendary club but how how many years
into the business before you got to
Caroline it it took a while yeah she was
six weeks everything is all topsy-turvy
man
all right so let me give the full
introduction you can see Brian Regan
around the country you can go to his
website Brian Regan that's our e GaN
dot-com and his comedy tour
he's also his role of Mugsy in the
second season of Loudermilk Tuesdays at
10:00 Eastern and Pacific on the
audience network so he's an actor and
check out him
they stand up dates you can go to his
website for that as well all right where
are you touring now etiquette I know ya
have uh I think Stamford Connecticut
tonight Torrington Connecticut tomorrow
night
Albany Saturday and Burlington Vermont
on Sunday do you adjust your act in
accordance to what part of the country
you're in not that much no I just kind
of do what I do but I do notice there
are shorter fuses in the audience in the
Northeast you know like if you perform
like in Minneapolis or something like
that you know the crowds are very
appreciative they're they're looking at
you like we're we're just happy you're
here you know and if you make them laugh
on top of it it's gravy but if you
perform like in Boston or Philadelphia
or New York no patience they can they
are great audiences but short fuse like
you better you better get your foot in
the door quick because if you don't get
them laughing quick they're gonna
they're gonna turn on you and they're
gonna let you know I know that I brought
this up before to you and I meant it as
a compliment but I could see where it
feels like the label is Brian Regan he
doesn't go blue he has it your your
stand-up act and my kids are the ones
who told me about you and you go and you
can take your family there and it's not
like it's watered down
it's just smarter humor where you just
don't use curse words but are you
bothered by the label of hey Brian he
doesn't use curse words it's it's a
double-edged sword you know sometimes I
wonder if it keeps more people away
seriously it brings in yeah I wondered
that's like a G rating on a movie
sometimes a movie doesn't want a G
rating because people go I don't want to
go see that yeah it's sort of like that
with comedy I think if people don't know
anything
about me and here oh he's a clean
comedian people my god I want to go see
a guy whereas if they went and saw me
they hopefully would laugh and not even
think one way or the other about whether
it's clean you know and plus you know
you're becoming this big star you're you
comedians in cars with Seinfeld right
yeah so you not only one episode you've
done two episodes I was in the first ten
that he made before any of them were on
the Internet and then he asked me if I
wanted to do a second one so what's your
relationship with Seinfeld we're uh were
lovers are you okay I get this just in
Brian Regan as a boyfriend in series -
no man
we're comedy friends okay you know uh
it's always a weird thing - like I never
want to act like I'm you know we don't
go to Central Park and fly kites
together you know but we're friends in
the comedy world he saw me years ago
when I before he had his TV show he uh
he saw me do a set and he was huge in
the comedy world but he hadn't had he
was on an estate calm yet and he saw me
do a set in New York and said some good
things to me and uh so since then you
know it's why I've opened for him and
some theaters around the country and
stuff like that and you know what about
and then Letterman you were on how many
times 25 times 28 28 times on Letterman
very very fortunate okay how did
Letterman find you well you have to
audition you know I mean I auditioned
not for him but for like a show producer
you know and I had auditioned of a few
times and not gotten it and then you
audition and then they go yeah we think
we think it'll work out wait wait you go
in prior to the show or in a comedy club
oh okay you know you go in a comedy club
you don't go on a showcase which means
like the producer will come out and
watch five six comedians who might be
but you know that they're coming out
yeah for you to audition for Letterman
correct and then you do it you wait to
see if there's a phone call the next day
and what was that first appearance like
it's hard to explain the more nervous
with with 14 ritzy then giving out a
Super Bowl trophy the nerves when your
it was very funny when you're backstage
before a show like that it's it's pretty
intense but that's part of the fun to me
it's like you know any golfer can make a
four-foot putt but can you make it when
you need to win the US Open it's sort of
like that with comedy it's like well a
lot of people can be funny but can you
be cut funny when this curtain opens and
you got to walk out and there's cameras
and the whole thing can you do it then
do you remember are you I don't know if
you're telling a joke listening for the
audience but you also want to hear if
Letterman laughs are you aware of that
yes because well he has a distinct
cackle if you will is this unusual way
of laughing and there are there are
times when you're out there doing
stand-up and you'll hear him like go
yeah and you almost want to you almost
want to stop you always want to stop
they go I don't care about any of you I
care about that you know but you can't
stop he's Brian Regan stand-up comedian
and he is you can see him in the role of
Mugsy that season two of Loudermilk own
audience at channel 239 on Direct TV how
do you deal with hecklers I'm not good
at it I I'm not good at dealing with
them I don't have any go-to lines if
somebody heckles to me I'm thrown you
would think this far into the into my
career I'd have some surefire comeback
one time I was on stage and I got
heckled and I was like you know I just
dealt with it the best way I could I got
off stage and the other comedians were
mocking me they were mocking my response
they said they said please stop you're
hurting my feelings
[Laughter]
come back wow that's that sharp with ya
please stop you're hurting my feelings
man that's a singer I think Lenny Bruce
used that to one time I mentioned that I
got an email from do you know Mark
Ridgely I do know mark okay so so he
sold you out he said ask Brian about
playing wide receiver at Heidelberg
college yes got your butt kicked team
was oh and 27 hey you guys never won
again no that's not true
we were the Ohio Athletic Conference has
a blue division and a red division at
least used to when I was there and one
season we were Oh an eight but the
playoffs were the first place team plays
the first place team 2nd place 2nd 3rd
place turd all the way down so the last
Flex team played the last place team for
some reason ok so we went to a playoff
kick there's no way they call it that we
were oh and eight and we go we played up
the worst team in the other division and
we beat them and we were coming back on
the bus like all confused as how we were
supposed to feel you know
yeah we weren't great but I'm glad I
went there because I was able to play I
mean I had friends that went to Notre
Dame and played football I was for a
really good high school football team we
sent like 13 guys to college and a lot
of them went to major colleges but you
know a lot of them weren't able to play
as much as I was able to play at
Heidelberg your nickname was rip rip
because I slept all the time Rip Van
[Laughter]
Winkle was always sleeping you have a
bit where the postgame press conference
yeah this blew up with sports fans
didn't you do this on Fallon yes okay
you can you I I hate the postgame press
conferences because and they're starting
to learn but for the most part they do
not mic the question askers and it
drives me crazy you see the coach or the
athlete sitting at the table
and you're watching this that was a
coaching decision
three maybe four can you repeat the
question I thought you were gonna say
yes or no you're right they say should
mic them I do want to get your expert
opinion on this now this is fritzy's
opening joke so first words out of his
mouth that Caroline's so the great Brian
Regan is going to address this packed
house in Caroline's so I'm at a sporting
event the other night and at least three
different people come over to me asking
if I'm sitting in their seats so I don't
know if it's a few guys ever deal with
this if you go to a concert or sporting
events how difficult is to [ __ ] seats
and concert or a sporting event think
about it it's got all the information
you need right there on the ticket
section row seat number section row C
number it's really really not that
complicated I've got these people coming
over to me and saying I think we're in
the same thing not only they not in my
seats they're all the way on the other
side of they really couldn't have been
further from where I'm at so I don't
understand section row seat let's let's
get it together just some people I just
can't deal with that's not bad okay I
think that's funny
but but hitting it a little too hard at
the end like you know but good good good
premise David Spade said it was a good
setup yeah like you can have
observational humor without humor and
that's what it felt like it was just
sort of like it was missing something at
the very end it was just observation
yeah yeah there's no punch
or comedy plus he doesn't address the
audience Brian yeah I didn't do that
everybody doing tonight I thought like
that would be a weak way of getting like
that applause to say that hey how's
everybody doing tonight that's that's
supposed to be a negative that people
are not supposed to say how's everybody
doing but I but I do it occasionally
when you need yeah but you're a nice guy
and Fritzi went blue right out of night
I heard the bleep word punch it punch it
that's a crutch well if you scramble a
little bit sometimes that's when that
word comes in I mean I don't work that
way but I know a lot of you ever yeah
yeah I mean I when I first started I was
I was not a hundred percent clean when I
started I had some had some blue jokes
some dirty jokes but it was always like
five percent of my act so I I took him
out not because I wanted to be wholesome
because I'm anal I wanted to be a
hundred percent something speaking of
anal here's another joke that Fritz he
had recently from a friend of mine that
if your mom is still taking your
temperature rectally when you're in high
school it's a little past the time where
that's acceptable my little sister in
the room with the actress sketch trying
to make a drawing of it and everything's
just really really inappropriate I can't
look at Vaseline me the same way and she
why shouldn't have any good aim so you
can imagine how painful I was very
visual
they say comedy is pictures very
interesting crowd was into it a little
bit yeah well crowds like crowds like
when you get earthy and dirty and low
yeah yeah go low huh any advice for
Fritzi for the next stand-up big stage
Los Angeles Sunset Strip Comedy Store
you played the comedy store I'm sure
slow down you're a little on a quick
side I get nervous and anxious and it
makes you start talking real quick you
got a drawn in man the slow it don't go
super slow but you got to just slow it
down and the crowd will go they'll lean
forward when you're when you're chasing
them
they they pull back and you worry at
least I have that what you think you
worried that you're gonna forget what
you're gonna say in the order of how you
have in your head so that makes you talk
faster too to make sure you get it out
but he doesn't write down his chills and
learn your own act that's that's an
important component to comedy fritzy you
got to write it down I had written some
notes down but then I didn't bring it up
with me onto the stage because I didn't
want to like feel like we'll be looking
at index card instead of making eye
contact
would you write down everything you say
word for word not at the ultimately at
first it's an idea and you have you may
give it a beginning middle and an end
and then I'll try it on stage but I tape
every show and that way while I'm on
stage sometimes sometimes I think the
best writing takes place when you're on
stage in the heat of the moment you
figure out a more concise way of getting
to the point is there a go-to joke you
have when you need to like when you know
that maybe you you've gone over to I was
joking with Dave because I do these
corporate shows where sometimes know the
audience they don't know who I am you
know don't know I'm so bad at selling
myself on tour well I hate when I do a
corporate event and they bring that as a
surprise guest please don't bring that
as a surprise surprise we've you've
worked all year to get to this great
moment yes you've Award winners and as
us what big surprise surprise guy you've
never heard
yes so I hit the stage and they have no
idea who I am and I used to do a bit
years ago about dogs barking at three
o'clock in the morning and I never
understood why they did that and my joke
was what if people were like that and I
do a guy yelling but I know I'm having a
bad show
I started barking once again the guy you
don't know
he's Brian Regan yeah yeah come out and
see him get to know him Brian Regan calm
you could also see him in his role of
Mugsy second season of Loudermilk on
audience that channel 239 Tuesdays at
10:00 Eastern and Pacific it's always
great when you stop by thank you and I
we appreciate you joining us is always
prank you so much for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]